skillful agile and fast
they call her the wasp she seems intense
it's got he unleashed something powerful
we need your help oh boy you owe us and
man and the wasp teaming up
oh man and the wasps everywhere July 6
we unleashed something colorful we have
to stop her if you want to do something
right you make a list
we have to team two we got to fight dose
three we're gonna try some toast
that seems like should be part of to to
a
watch this
Oh also we have to save the world that's
major we can't forget that
like guys like you
mess it up every time
maybe you just need a partner
dr. PIM I actually heard what happened
to you it's crazy could be ghosts
stole your tech field chance you got
this
and man the wasp teaming up follow my
lead
she seems more intense
[Applause]
we unleashed something powerful
the chance to practice together there is
another person I can take maybe I'm
doing it wrong you have no idea what I'm
capable of
she just wanted to give me a hug wish me
luck really
watch this
[Applause]
sorry I'm messing around
wish I had a suit
even with like mineral powers or maybe
even just a suit with no powers yeah
you